ever wondered how large enterprise scale
systems are designed
before major software development starts
we have to choose a suitable
architecture that will provide us
with the desired functionality and
quality attributes
according to wikipedia an architectural
pattern is a general
reusable solution to a commonly
occurring problem in
software architecture within a given
context
in this video i will briefly explain the
most important architectural
patterns used in the enterprise app
development today
pattern one layered pattern this is the
most common architecture pattern that is
also known as the
entire architecture here the software
is divided into units called layers
there are usually four tiers of layers
presentation layer
application layer business logic layer
and
data access layer each of the layers has
a specific role
and responsibility for example the
presentation layer is usually
responsible for handling user interface
among the advantages of the layered
pattern is that a lower layer can be
used by different higher layers
however this pattern performs poorly in
the high performance applications
because it is not efficient to go
through multiple layers to fulfill a
business request
the layered pattern is usually used in
building general desktop applications
as well as relatively simple web apps it
is a good choice for situations with a
very tight budget
and time constraints pattern 2
pipe filter pattern in many enterprise
apps
a single event triggers a sequence of
processing steps
each performing a specific function for
example
let's assume a new customer order
arrives
one requirement may be that the message
is encrypted to prevent eavesdroppers
from spying on a customer's order
a second requirement is that the
messages contain
authentication information in the form
of a digital certificate
to ensure that orders are placed only by
trusted customers
to meet these requirements we need to
transform a stream of complex messages
into a stream of unique simple plain
text order messages
without additional data fields the pipes
and filters architecture divides a
larger processing task
into a sequence of smaller independent
processing steps
or filters that are connected by
channels or
pipes the pattern is often used in
compilers
where the consecutive filters perform
lexical analysis
parsing semantic analysis and code
generation
pattern three client server pattern
in the client server architecture there
are two main components
the client which is the service
requester and the server
which is the service provider although
both client and server
may be located within the same system
they often communicate over a network on
separate hardware
the advantage of using the client server
pattern is an ease of modeling
a set of services where clients can
request them
among the disadvantages of this pattern
is that the server can be a performance
bottleneck
and a single point of failure on top of
that
decisions about where to locate
functionality in the client or in the
server
are often complex and costly to change
after a system has been built
typical real-world use cases of the
client server pattern include
online applications such as email
document sharing and banking pattern 4
model view controller pattern the user
interface is typically the most
frequently modified portion of an
interactive application
how can user interface functionality be
kept separate from application
functionality
and yet still be responsive to user
input or to changes in the underlying
applications data
and how can multiple views of the user
interface be created
maintained and coordinated when the
underlying application data changes
the solution is to use the model view
controller pattern
which separates application
functionality into three kinds of
components
model which contains the core
functionality and data
view which displays the information to
the user
where more than one view may be defined
and controller
which handles the input from the user
the model view controller pattern is
commonly used in the web frameworks
such as django and rails pattern five
event bus pattern the modern enterprise
software
is often built as a distributed system
that can service asynchronously arriving
messages
associated with high volume of events
the event bus pattern has four major
components
event source event listener channel and
event bus
sources publish messages to particular
channels on an event bus
listeners subscribe to particular
channels
listeners are notified of messages that
are published to a channel to which they
have subscribed before
the advantage of using this pattern is
that new publishers
subscribers and connections can be added
easily
however the scalability might be a
problem for this pattern
as all messages travel through the same
bus
the event bus pattern is often used in
android development
e-commerce applications and notification
services
pattern six micro services architecture
the modern enterprise apps are required
to support a variety of browsers
and native mobile clients these days the
applications
usually handle client requests by
executing business logic
accessing a database exchanging messages
with other systems
and returning responses in this regard
monolithic applications can become too
large and complex for efficient support
and deployment
the solution is to build applications as
micro services
each service is independently deployable
and scalable
and has its own api boundary different
services can be written
in different programming languages
manage their own database
and developed by different teams many
use cases are applicable for a
microservices architecture
especially those that involve an
extensive data pipeline
pattern 7 broker pattern
this pattern is used to structure
distributed systems with decoupled
components
these components can interact with each
other by remote service invocations
a broker component is responsible for
the coordination of communication among
components servers publish their
capabilities to a broker
clients request a service from the
broker and the broker then redirects the
client to a suitable service from its
registry
the broker pattern allows for dynamic
change addition
deletion and relocation of objects and
it makes distribution
transparent to the developer however
among the disadvantages of the broker
pattern is that it requires
standardization of service descriptions
this pattern is often used in the
message broker software
such as apache activenq apache kafka
rabbit and q and jboss messaging
pattern 8 peer-to-peer pattern
in this pattern individual components
are known as peers
peers may function both as a client
requesting services from other peers
and as a server providing services to
other peers
a peer may act as a client or as a
server
or as both and it can change its role
dynamically with time
the peer-to-peer pattern supports
decentralized computing
and is highly robust in the failure of
any given node
besides it is highly scalable in terms
of resources and
computing power however there is no
guarantee about
quality of service as nodes cooperate
voluntarily
on top of that security is difficult to
ensure
and the system performance often depends
on the number of nodes
this pattern is used in the file sharing
networks
such as ganutella and g2 multimedia
protocols
such as p2ptv and pdtp
as well as in cryptocurrency based
products such as bitcoin
pattern 9 blackboard pattern
this pattern is useful for problems for
which no deterministic solution
strategies are known
the blackboard pattern consists of three
main components
blackboard which is a structured global
memory
containing objects from the solution
space
knowledge source which is specialized
modules with their own representation
control component which selects
configures
and executes modules all the components
have
access to the blackboard components may
produce
new data objects that are added to the
blackboard
components look for particular kinds of
data on the blackboard
and may find these by pattern matching
with the existing knowledge source
the advantage of using this pattern is
that extending the structure of the data
space
is easy however modifying the structure
of the data space
is hard as all applications are affected
this pattern is often used in speech
recognition
protein structure identification and
summer signals interpretation
pattern 10 master slave pattern
this pattern consists of two parties
master
and slaves the master component
distributes the work among
identical slave components and computes
a final result from the results which
the slaves return
the advantage of using the master slave
pattern
is the accuracy in which the execution
of a service
is delegated to different slaves with
different implementations
however this pattern can only be applied
to a problem that can be decomposed
the master slave pattern is usually used
in database replications
where the master database is regarded as
the authoritative source
and the slave databases are synchronized
to it
if you found this video useful i would
appreciate it if you smash the like
button
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding tech channel and click
on the notification bell enjoy the rest
of your day